you complain about always like dripping
moist stuff out of your butt oh you get
mucus yeah you get the mucus plug yeah
yeah you get the milk sauce
is that not true you get mucus ass yeah
yeah it is but I'm not a doctor but I
would call it mucus I would say mucus is
a sign of inflammation yeah we call it
mucus maybe it's mucus mucus okay it's
slimy right well my dad had it well then
your dad had mucus [__] yeah because
one time he was beating my brother he my
brother woke him up from a nap and he
was playing keyboards my brother yeah
and he had a friend over my dad walked
in completely naked took the keyboard
smashed it over my brother's head yeah
yeah and then when he turned around he
provided a good laugh
because he had toilet paper sticking out
of his [__] and that's when we knew
there was something going on and so I
think he probably had a hemorrhoid then
he probably had one that was bleeding he
thinks no he had no my mom the mucus
wouldn't you wouldn't keep the toilet
paper for the mucus you wouldn't no
because you don't keep it up your nose
when you've got a bit of snot there
okay okay can I say this though I think
you're wrong because I smelled it what
does it smell like you smelled it your
mucus your ass my [__] the the juice
the [__] juice it would smell like
[__] it's been around [__] man the mucus
would be yes you're right scientifically
yes you're right yeah yeah I think
you're right so your parents were
beaters
I used to hit you yeah yeah my parents
were hitters they're violent yeah and um
my parents were like my my mother used
to go my father not so much he was all
right but my mum used to go hell for
leather man she used to beat the [__]
out yeah and the um trauma that I did
cause you trauma yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you do EMDR and stuff to
get through it or no no I've been to
therapy about it and stuff like that and
the resentment you hold towards it and
all those stuff but then you just got to
realize that people were doing their
best I mean she loved me she's just
doing her best yeah I just don't that
argument you know they did the best they
can right is could have done better
could have done it without the hitting
but what are you gonna do how hard is it
not to hit your I mean that's a bit when
I had a child that's when I went into
therapy yeah because until then I just
thought that's what parents do and then
when I looked at my son when he was
about five or six and that's when I was
beaten relentlessly
and I was like I could never [__]
backhand this kid yeah yeah I I wouldn't
what Joy would I it's not like I'm
struggling every time I see my son I
want to punch him in the face you know
what I mean yeah it's not even a
struggle for me yeah that's the bit I
didn't get that's what I'm at I was
exactly kind of essentially what I was
asking you know how the resistance if
you have to resist it there's something
really wrong my brother my mother was in
hospital this is towards the end of her
life but my mother was in hospital and
she'd broken something and it healed up
and she was going through physical
therapy and all that type of stuff and
she had the therapist come in like a
like a actual therapist therapist come
in and talk to her and she she'd
obviously given him all this like oh I
wish I could walk better but my the boys
aren't very nice to me and they don't
give me much encouragement and all this
type of stuff right and so my brother
who's a cop but he actually was in his
uniform he he walks in there to visit
her like this and uh this therapist
caught him and he said and Mum was in
bed all [__] hug tucked up
and she goes out and he goes hey look I
was talking to your mum and she was such
a great mum to you boys and uh she um
she looks She's she's trying really hard
at Physical Therapy but she's feeling
like she's not getting enough
encouragement from you guys so if you
could say things like way to go mum and
you're doing great mum
I think that would go a long way is she
sitting all smugging her bed yeah and my
father my brother goes like this let me
stop you right there
yeah and he goes I lock up people every
[__] day
for doing less than this what this woman
did to me
wow we should have been put into [__]
so yeah yeah like Social Services right
yeah so I don't know what [__] This
Woman's been telling you yeah and then
the guys like this okay well I feel like
you have some unresolved things and I'll
just leave you to it right and my mother
said as he was leaving she went after
[__] sake Danny it was the 70s we all
beat our kids
that was the 70s though because I
remember my mum hitting me in
supermarkets yeah open hand slapping a
Superman yeah yeah yeah and you're like
you can't do that now yeah yeah and then
I would I would go to school with a
bloody lip same but also even like
threatening I remember being threatened
out loud in front of other people like
wait till we get home and everyone
cheering for my mother
you wait oh yeah go get her when you get
home and they would all celebrate each
other's beating when you got yeah when
you go when you got hit I remember
distinctly being hit hitting this cereal
are boxes coming down yeah and other
parents like this oh so he must have
done something wrong
we were in trouble yeah yeah yeah but
um what's changed though
um well and also my question to you is
is that
because I believe that I wouldn't change
anything of my past because everything
that happened led up to this moment and
I love my life now right so it's like
did all those events need to happen for
me to